of an ecosystem for trust
this proposal I think has retained the
ecosystem for trust at the same time
however the all these proposals driven
by fear
which are covered mean that this
proposal is not balanced enough and that
I think will hind our efforts to become
leaders in the world in terms of AI
so in my view the proposal will be
voting talking about today and voting on
tomorrow should be tailored so as to
ensure that we can our industry turns
this into success story
the commission and standardization
organizations must now ensure that they
act quickly so as to ensure they provide
support measures and establish technical
standards
in my view in the trial of negotiations
we should try to ensure that we
eliminate
overlap and contributions with other
sexual rules and digital legislation we
have to ensure we eliminate all of those
I think we should also ensure that
within the European Union
we do indeed ensure that we have the
same rules everywhere
we should try to ensure that we do don't
repeat the mistakes of the gdpr
and I think it's important that we
ensure that data sets
be properly trained I think there's real
room for improvement there
and one final point
uh small and medium-sized Enterprises
and startups
will run the risk of paying the price
with the all these expensive rules on AI
we have to ensure that they have access
to waivers
and perhaps to ensure that we can
intervene in the supply chain so as to
ensure that we can pave the way to a
europe-wide success in this new field
the long way he
thank you the next speaker is Vice
President of the commission Mr
this is indeed
big
it is historic this debates and the vote
tomorrow
I want to congratulate the European
Parliament the repertoires and the
Shadows from this impressive work
not only in relating to the proposal but
also in the preparation
in the in-depth understanding of what it
is that we're dealing with
and I think this is what has enabled you
to strike a compromise on striking 3300
amendments and developing a
comprehensive legislative approach on
general purpose AI
an impossible task for the unprepared
not even an easy task for the
well-prepared as the parliament had
prepared
but just a few words about why we table
this proposal in the first place
because when it comes to technology the
most important thing when you embrace it
is that you can trust it
and only by embracing something can you
control it if you keep it at arm's
length very difficult to get a tight
grip
and what we can do here is to create
trust legal certainty to enable AI to
develop in a positive manner
to serve our society our Ambitions the
sectors the businesses the industry we
can do amazing thing with artificial
intelligence when we can trust it
when we started uh our journey I
frequently got the question why are you
regulating AI this will hamper
Innovation why did it not just let it go
but I think by now everyone realizes
that's this is the important moment yes
this is the time
and also this has matured the outer
world to see that the risk-based
approach the focus on the use of
technology that is the future proof one
I think this is also a chance to put a
big line under the Brussels effect
the work of this Parliament
is not to be seen in isolation it is to
be seen with the ambition of democracy
not only catching up with technology but
shaping how we use technology in the
best interest of the human being I
commend you and I look very much forward
to the debate the vote tomorrow and the
process from there on thank you very
much
[Applause]
thank you commissioner and the next
speaker
is commissioner putum
Mr President
honorable members before going any
further
I would like to turn to complement the
rampultation shadows for the various
committees
and all the members of this house
for the huge amount of work they have
done
on the artificial intelligence Act
this legislative proposal is part of our
efforts to organize the information area
within Europe in our internal Market
revolving around four main police that I
will briefly
mentioned with digital platforms that
the creation of a single data market
ggaa the data Act
securing the digital area with nispr and
cyber solidarity
and now the artificial intelligence act
to back that all up
in 2021 we tabled a proposal in the
commission
it has to be said that altogether we
found ourselves grappling with a very
complex issue
there's an intersection of a wide range
of interests and principles here the
technology of course which can just make
progress the proper framework for
applications respect for our values is
so important as is Safety and Security
but I
feel profoundly convinced that we are
the continent
with the democratic system best placed
to govern this regulation in a
transparent balanced responsible
proportionate way
undoubtedly what we have here is also
the possibility of gradually phasing in
a new world order
but let us return to the AI act itself
we didn't wait until people called upon
us to take action in the union Europe
has shown that it could think ahead of
the curve because since 2021 we've all
been working together on this FBI
regulation
this endeavor is what has put us in a
position to be the the first legalism in
the world to be debating clear
nature pool it
proportionate rules in the face of some
of the possible applications of AI while
making the most of technological
progress and Innovation at the same time
what we're doing is is not pressing the
pause button as you sometimes hear
people saying on on the contrary we're
trying to react in a politically
responsible way to provide a clear
regulated
safe framework and that's what we're all
doing together in Europe now regarding
parliament's report
now under debate I would like to welcome
the approach which is risk-based
the commission had
proposed that of course
but all the reporters have run with this
and also note that the the report
includes some definition of hiring um
a high risk and governance amongst other
welcome Innovations
now if I could say something about
General use and generative AI
that's something that lies at the heart
of many International debates today it
seems to me that a major task across in
negotiations will be to ensure that in
AI legislation provides palpable
responses to the charges faced by
generalized AI particularly generative
AI systems
such as Chachi BT for example
I note that European Parliament to the
council and the commission share their
understanding of the need to take action
and to ensure transparency regarding
generative AI to be clear
we need to label anything that is AI
generated images thanks by using
watermarking this is a central element
if we are to build up the confidence of
providers and consumers
there are other challenges such as as
bias and disinformation there's a
crucial challenges for society
particularly as we're coming into a
major europe-wide cycle of Elections and
many member states will be affected by
our proposals and so I feel that we need
to work together
in parallel with negotiations on the AI
Act
as we know this will only come into
fourth in 2026 so that right as of now
once this has been um
adoptable upon following trilogue we can
send out a clear message to all AI
players
writers for today that this is the
meaning behind the artificial
intelligence pact put forward a few
weeks ago the idea is that we should
support firms
in implementing the future rollout of
rules on AI once this legislation has
gone through of course
that's to ensure that the transition can
go through as easily harmoniously and
fast as possible
of course
we're not trying to preempt negotiations
to come but we we want the major
guidelines
through as quickly as as possible
and we're entering into commitment with
all the the stakeholders and we have
positive signs lastly may I make it very
clear that of course we'll accept a no
interference whatsoever at this stage of
our Democratic process in the European
Union on such a central issues as
artificial intelligence from anyone
International Forum or private invested
interest
I welcome the fact that the the code
registration banking progress on this
and I trust that department to adopt his
position tomorrow which will allow us to
um move without any delay into the
trilogue you can rely on on myself in
the commission and all our staff
to work together with the two branches
of the legislature until an agreement is
forthcoming thank you
the president thank you now Mrs Solis
Palace has
floor from the environmental committee
thank you very much president
commissioner we are talking here about
historic legislation Europe has always
been a Pioneer when it comes to AI this
is technology which can bring with it
great benefits but which clearly also
poses risks in terms of fundamental
freedoms and disinformation this is why
very much welcome the focus in this
proposal it draws distinction technology
and use we don't condemn AI per se but
risky practices
it's very clear to us that certain
aspects are unacceptable anything which
is discriminatory or harmful
and in in that case they should be
banned we need to have safe transparent
rules with accountability so as to
ensure that high risk use such as health
applications environmental transport and
Justice be properly regulated
we should also recognize that we need a
flexible law which provides incentives
for companies to use it so as to ensure
that they can adapt quickly to the
enormous progress which is being made
we've seen this recently with generative
AI chat gbt
in which time is pressing so as to
ensure that we can establish rules
Europe I need to take a big step forward
and this law will help us establish
trust amongst our citizens and ensure
that we remain in the Vanguard of
efforts to develop AI foreign
foreign
commissioner colleagues the reporters it
was a pleasure working with you from the
transport side of things and today's
vote places Europe at the Forefront of
becoming a global hub for cutting-edge
Innovation channeling the potential of
fair accessible transparent and
trustworthy AI for our citizens the ex
strives to achieve an important balance
encouraging investment digitalization
and technological progress was
regulating via a risk-based approach
respecting our European values and
fundamental rights our strides in this
field must continuously seek to improve
our quality of life relying on
human-centric models keeping people in
the driver's seats while also ensuring
that AI serves as an enabler for
inclusive mobility and transport all
this can only be achieved if we ensure
that our Workforce is sufficiently
skilled and our samis are kept on board
fostering article AI built on
responsibility and clear liability will
create a culture of trust for consumers
and investors alike incentivizing the
uptake of technologies that can improve
the life of European citizens and the
resilience of critical and fresh
infrastructure whether it is in the
health and transport Fields thank you
thank you very much
moving on now to the speakers on behalf
of the groups first of all Miss cluner
for the Epp so this is a groundbreaking
piece of legislation it is among the
first Global attempts to regulate AI
an AI has the capacity to solve the most
pressing issues including climate change
or serious illness and we want to lay
the foundations for doing this here in
the European Union
this law could become the de facto
Global approach to regulating Ai and
especially new types of AI like
Foundation models we cannot do this
entirely on our own but we should be
leaders in ensuring that this technology
is developed and used in a responsible
ethical manner while also supporting
Innovation and economic growth it's a
clear signal of our openness and our
willingness to engage with our
International Partners on AI that we've
aligned the definition with that of the
oecd
the air takes a risk-based approach and
if an AI system is high risk it must
need fairness transparency and safety
requirements systems are present an
unacceptable risk will be prohibited and
underpinning all of this is an ambitious
regime to support innovation in Europe
our proposals on Sandbox will help
ensure that they are developed in a safe
a responsible manner in areas that offer
the most value and Ingenuity in the EU
is that we're among the first to tackle
the fast moving and evolving technology
with a concrete legislative proposal on
how to address those powerful Foundation
models to build trust and provide
transparency and oversight of these
systems the absolute absolute minimum
that we need to offer here is
transparency it must be clear that this
content has not been made by a human and
we also go one step further and ask
developers if these large models to be
more transparent and share their
information with providers and how these
systems were trained and how they were
developed this should address and also
the environmental sustainability of
these systems so this legislation will
contribute to building public trust and
certainty with AI by establishing
regulatory oversight a body and ensuring
that we have openness and transparency
thank you
Mr fitana first indeed
and a commissioner uh all the colleagues
spoke about the benefits I'm not going
to repeat it I also believe that we are
on the verge of adopting legislation
that will find this team balance between
the protection of fundamental rights
protecting the rule of law and promoting
Innovations at the same time I have to
raise some concerns because some
colleagues from Epp they
already tabled some amendments
concerning biometric identity they had
our almost watering down all that we
agreed in the imco labor committee a
meeting and negotiating to a point which
make all those by uh bans meaningless
and I'll give you this story I remember
that story we all remember this Pentagon
project I believe that used AI systems
to detect and to identify humans and out
of eight troops nobody was detected all
those guys they use different amusing
tricks some somersaulting for 300 meters
some hitting cardboard boxes and one
even look like 43 don't even ask me what
that means well the AI could not detect
them because it was never trained of
dates of people doing so and it does not
possess the creative intelligence of a
human being
colleagues from Epp will try to make the
case how these systems could be used to
catch criminals but one thing is very
clear to me those who want to hide from
AI systems will always find a way to do
so and always the innocent will suffer
so it's not a question of whether the AI
system have the potential to result in
racially biased and discriminatory
outcomes we actually know for sure
that this is the case we see this
confirmation
of this in the data provided of multiple
ngos
we keep seeing it during the Libre
mission to Washington DC and we have
heard it even from the EU High
Commissioner for human rights and no AI
is not dangerous only when used by
autocratic governments when attacking
when a Technologies float it's flowed no
matter who uses and for what purposes
thank you
Francis
now on behalf of renew Europe we have
Mrs Han
yeah
potential of
a i is so significant we can hardly
imagine in all areas of life education
work or health and for that reason it's
very important with the AI act We Lay
the foundation as to what kind of AI we
want to have in a liberal democracy
because there are risks and
opportunities in the use
biometric
facial recognition of as we know from
China that we should not have that in
the EU so we have to have very clear
rules at the same time we have to
support innovation made in Europe for
example being able to experience
experiment in a sandbox so that I think
that's why we have to have standards for
such generative Ai and not just a
Prohibition of it so we don't want to
have
um over regulation we have to support
citizens right and really set our
business sectors free so we end up being
a hot spot for artificial intelligence
thank you very much
our next speaker Mrs sparintuck for the
greens
what can we do to ensure that we shape
the future of society will allow
computers to decide what's right or
wrong when it comes to identifying who's
a criminal and the basis of where you
live what sport club you're a member of
and where your parents are from or do we
look for what's good in people and give
them an honest opportunity
do we choose for a society in which
people are constantly persecuted by
so-called smart cameras enabling
governments and corporate interests in
exactly where you are and what you're
doing every day or do we opt for a
society in which you can walk freely on
the streets
when it comes to Smart intelligence we
have to make fundamental choices about
our future
we are elected representative of the
people
and will we in the future be elected via
solid rules or will our future be in the
hands of tech companies and so-called
Innovations
I think that we should look try to find
the good in AI we should in that part
which enables us to bring about progress
for people in the environment while
limiting the more detrimental sites
so after a year and a half and hundreds
of hours of negotiations I'm proud that
the European Parliament is now starting
to make choices
we can vote tomorrow and a strong right
to information and consultation
so as to ensure that people will be
powerless in the face of computers and
they'll know an algorithm is being used
a compulsory test for human rights
before AI is used strict regulations
about how you generate and train systems
and how to use data
and obviously this is particularly
important when it comes to
discriminatory data and
and we also have to ensure that for
major models such as GDP we have
extremely strict rules for the first
time around the world where we in the
world will be having a report on
environmental impact of Standards
applying to systems such as DBT
we also want to have a ban on unethical
Technologies such as emotion gender
sexuality or real-time reaction
recognition
in the public area
Europe must
choose its own way rather than being
subservient to the US and China we have
to ensure that this new technology in
Europe be reliable ethically acceptable
and environmentally friendly in this way
we can protect our democracy while
ensuring that this technology we use
will be to to will help us rather than
damaging us thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr radovski for eco
foreign
it opens up huge possibilities in a wide
range of areas of life the economy but
just like I did new medicine this new
remedy
does entail a number of risks and so we
must Ensure
that while developing these Technologies
we also acknowledge the dangers
of course we're assuming
there will be more benefits than
hindrances as a result that's why we
need good European regulation
but we also need a good partnership
to ensure the kind of AI we use will be
safe and ethical as far as our ECR group
is concerned so the primary concern
is to strike the right balance between
new applications for business
particularly smes in the technology
sector while also
having a high level of protection for
citizens in general and consumers
specifically I'd like to thank everyone
for the efforts that's have gone into
this delicate compromise I'd like to
thank the teams and the experts who've
contributed to our work AI
is already at our side
we urgently need this new regulation to
make sure that we have it properly under
control I hope that tomorrow we'll take
a further step forward in this direction
thank you
the debate we're having today on
artificial intelligence it creates
ethical dilemmas and difficult questions
on the one hand there's no doubt that
the technology has a great potential to
improve human life it may be more
efficient in many activities that we
have both in our private life and in our
business world but on the other hand
there are some
problems that that are quite significant
for example protection of miners a
concern for about deep fakes I think
these are genuine concerns they require
a reaction based on common sense so we
have to have a positive approach to see
at a European level we could find a good
direction to go in to regulate AI but
one of our concerns in historical terms
is that when we have technological
change there's been too little
protection of freedom of expression and
it seems as though this is just handed
over to the tech Giants ending up with a
kind of self-censor which really uh
distorts the fundamental rights of the
users of those platforms so we have
quite a lot of concern that when we have
a regular relation in this area that we
have to ensure our protection of
fundamental rights especially protection
of the freedom of expression so that
really has to be a considerable uh to
take into account when we address this
the next speaker
ladies and gentlemen
and if this law on AI if it's adopted
this would be the first time that we
have such a regulations very ambition
indeed in fact the first time in the
world that we are addressing these
matters and for that reason it shouldn't
just be ambitious because we're the
first but above all this has to be
ambitious in the sense of truly serving
to protect our citizens and protect
their fundamental rights protect their
health unfortunately they're taxed which
came from the deliberations of the
Committees is not unfortunately
ambitious enough
oh
in fact
in the the provisions on access of
people to
um
education uh and in when applying for
jobs I think there's really quite a lot
of risk involved these should be
considered high-risk areas
I I think there really are it is going
to be quite a risk for our employees in
the same time I don't think you could
this has not been addressed enough in
the text also the surveillance of
employees in the workplace by AI without
their consent that is really dangerous
indeed
that's a kind of corporate dystopia
where every step of every employee could
be watched in uh by their superiors
watched by their employers that's not
all right and we have to think of the
protection of our citizens
and we have made some amendments and
although and if they're not adopted then
it would not be possible for me to
support this proposal
thank you
the next
speakers Mr Urich
um
thank you president
now
pulling my own doctoral studies I think
nothing
in artificial intelligence seems to be
overwhelmingly one of the students asked
whether
a choice would have to be made between
human survival and
AI
he said he'd prefer to survive now if
artificial intelligence
goes wrong somewhere along the way who
will bear responsibility for the damage
caused imagine that AI actually kills
somebody
who will be held liable
the artificial new rental system
can
be mapped out in half an hour but
something that would take a human child
four years to to learn there are serious
risks with deep fakes too
so we need to give serious scrutiny
to the dance expressed by scientists
regarding
artificial intelligence
there are lots of prospects in this but
it's very dangerous and we must
regulated Mr President this AI act that
we're discussing today is a very
important piece of legislation and I
really thank the the rapporters and all
the sheriffs that already worked on this
for their diligent work because we need
a European approach and we need a
human-centered approach and I don't
think anybody also today in the debate
nobody has denied the benefits and the
potential of artificial intelligence to
make our societies more prosperous and
our economies more efficient and in
order to reach that potential we need to
make sure that AI is safe reliable and
trustworthy it needs to be developed and
used in an ethically and morally correct
way and the fundamental rights of our
citizens must be protected but we should
not only discuss how to protect our
citizens from AI we also need to make
sure we can use AI to protect our
citizens when a child goes missing every
second counts 76 percent of abducted
children that tragically do not survive
the abduction die within the first three
hours of their disappearance every
second counts and we need to make use of
all the instruments at our disposal to
prevent such tragedies from happening I
think that we need
a very realistic approach to this I
think the commission proposal was very
balanced on having targeted exceptions
to a ban on this kind of technology and
this is also reflected in our amendment
that we have tabled as an EVP to allow
the use of technology in very targeted
situations to find missing children to
prevent terrorist attacks and to fight
heavy criminals and I really count on
the support of all the colleagues for
such a balance and targeted proposal
thank you
Blanco
the next speaker is Mr Garcia Del Blanco
it's true to say this is a historic day
but this isn't a chance occurrence it's
the result of hard work over many years
thinking back to the document adopted on
artificial intelligence back in 2020 as
Rapport during the special committee on
that the enormous work which has been
done by the rapporters on this law
is act and I'd also like to thank of
course all the technical Stark in the
shadow reporters as well as the
commission for the work they've done
over these years which enables us to get
where we are it's important however to
send out a message in which we can
call for our students to tr to trust us
our
legislators have done a very important
task in in those sorts of technical
matters which are relevant to artificial
intelligence but we have to be
optimistic we have a humanistic approach
which places human beings needs at the
center of this and we have to have we
have an approach which enables to
respond flexibly to the challenges of
artificial intelligence the European
Union has chosen its own route it's
becoming mature autonomous and we can
act as a compass for the rest of the
world
this is the best side of Europe This is
the side of Europe which we want to
reject the rest of the world to Europe
which protects rights while at the same
time ensures that research high-tech and
Innovation can continue a foot in the
European Union please
sir
you have a blue card from Mrs Valentine
I understand do you accept it absolutely
of course
I actually had a blue card from the
previous for the previous speaker I
don't know why it still popped up
but
let's go
thank you vice president dear colleagues
we made it
over a year of negotiations the AI act
has finally reached plenary
the outcome is a careful balance it is a
text that promotes Innovation that
protects fundamental rights and fosters
trustworthy Ai and these three aims were
key to our work in the legal Affairs
committee we voted to guarantee that
open source developers who are driving
the AI Revolution would have space to
experiment without being buried in
paperwork we ensure that users of AI
have a right to an explanation because
for citizens to trust AI they have to
understand the decisions that it makes
and finally we ensure that citizens have
a right to recourse because decisions
made by AI should never be final
all of these Provisions have found their
way into the final text
this is great but tomorrow when we vote
we still have some decisions to make
make we need to ban biometric Mass
surveillance the police already have
efficient tools without infringing on
our fundamental rights we need to
prevent intrusive pseudoscientific
behavioral recognition we need to stop
heartless automated migration decision
making so I urge colleagues vote to ban
these dangerous practices vote for
trustworthy AI that respects our
fundamental rights thank you very much
to the two rapporteurs to all of the
shadows and to the commission for the
actual excellent work on this directive
thank you very much
foreign thank you president
I'd like to start by thanking the
reporter
we need to have trust and confidence
within Society
we through our work have established a
good compromise
I think everybody should respect that
and I say that in particular to our
colleagues from the EPP
we should respect that rather than
trying to go against it
uh honesty
trust and transparency those are the
cornerstones of this regulation
IAI Needs Trust from users
companies need reliability
they need to be able to count on
reliable guidelines so as to ensure that
sustainability and Innovative growth can
be pursued
however as EU legislators we ensure that
we show courage
in ensuring that whenever fundamental
rights are threatened where
discrimination appears where
environmental damage is threatened in
those cases that's where we draw a red
line
this is why we put forward a rule
so
we would ban any technology which
enables to see whether Manfred Weber is
in a good or bad mood
where people's emotions can be
established in the basis of their
expressions or hand gestures and no we
don't want any use of IA for Mass
surveillance we are not the people's
Congress of China we aren't the Russian
Duma we are the European parliaments
and we insist that we work within the
framework of freedom and democracy
most applications won't be affected by
this legislation that's a good thing
technology optimism and pessimism those
are the choices we think we've struck
the right balance that's to say
attention technological realism balance
is essential in this package we've come
down this road together and we'll
continue to walk down that road together
in the future thank you
thank you very much
the next speaker Mr rooken one and a
half minutes
thank you president
there's a flood coming to Europe
artificial intelligence can and probably
will be the greatest revolution of this
Century are living standards will change
completely
from for me first of all
the important thing is that we remain a
free Society
that means that people's basic rights
must be upheld so I'm very critical
towards European legislation
I usually oppose it but in this instance
I do support this proposal
you have to hold down rights if if we
don't want this AI flood to
um flood away our freedoms I'm against
Biometrics identification systems in
public spaces real time and subsequent
to the fact the European commission and
the council want that latter
responsibility as an exception
but exceptions always open doors
so I'm against this
if you're talking about terrorists or
children who are lost
or serious crime
or other suspects well or well and good
but before you know what's happened
step after step you're going to end up
with General AI surveillance so I'll
call upon you all not to go along with
this that flood
is coming to you we can't choose the
course attraction but we can build a
dike to protect our people let's do that
thank you now Mr Olivier has the floor
we don't
thank you veteran president
the digital Revolution or indeed the
cognitive resolution is now underway and
we support the eu's commitment to
provide the necessary regulation however
such a regulatory approach in itself is
not enough Specialists suggest that AI
will overtake human intelligence in 2029
and by 2045
artificial intelligence will be one
billion times more intelligence than all
human beings together
over the last 30 years the EU has missed
every technological Revolution telephone
space cyber defense
we've been left far behind when it comes
to artificial intelligence and the
digital economy and this might lead to
the downfall of our economy
will be left behind economically
speaking scientifically speaking
military speaking and politically
speaking
we've been left so far behind that we
are now a third world country when it
comes to technology works export the
digital economy sorry we'll export our
engineering technical Goods but we have
to import digital Goods every day which
goes by makes it harder for us to make
up for lost time
this failure makes it very difficult for
us to retain control of our military
systems our connected objects our
nuclear power stations air traffic
control and self-driving cars the
European Union has to put itself
together however can we do this after
having signed up to the degrowth
ideology which is proposed by the greens
how can a post-modernist society move
towards the third millennium if we've
accepted that we will be digital vassals
if we've given up all the Hope in
science and progress
because at the end of the day we've
given up on the very idea of wielding
power thank you
thank you the next speaker is Miss Ann's
do you have the floor good delegates in
Ai and communization of digitalization
is could has revolutionized the history
of
of men at the same time
a I can make the world better or
actually we can make a a greater Abyss
between people and Technology it doesn't
have any moral morals and
we don't can't afford to be naive when
we're talking about Ai and so the
blessings and the curses are very close
together in this case so in order to
develop this we need clear strict rules
precautionary principle otherwise this
is just going to be a play thing for the
powerful because you could use this to
surveil public space to identify uh
criminals uh perhaps however with AI
that you end up impacting the very
decisions that control our lives for
example education and employment and
health so we have to have courageous
regulation in order to prevent societal
damage by uh Mass surveillance which
already exists so we need prohibition
clear prohibitions for example complete
prohibition of any kind of facial
recognition facial recognition
technology not just now but
continuously we will not agree to any
regulation which will contribute to uh
increase the human rights violations on
the border
thank you Ms tortoise the next speaker
thank you president for today's debate I
asked artificial intelligence to write
me a speech in rhyme about regulating AI
this is the result
the AI Act is a crucial step we must
take to ensure that AI is developed
without mistake we must establish
ethical guidelines and rules to ensure
that AI is used as a tool for the
benefit of all citizens and society and
not just for profit or propriety the AI
act will provide a framework that's fair
and ensure that AI is used with care we
must protect the rights of every
European and ensure that AI is developed
with Precision so let us support the AI
activate conviction and ensure that AI
is developed with a Clear Vision let's
seize the opportunity to make a positive
impact and ensure that AI is developed
with a responsible fact thank you
colleagues for your attention let's work
together to ensure a bright AI Dimension
thank you
thank you Mr Schwab is the next speaker
Madame President Madam vice president
ladies and gentlemen
I'd like to start by expressing my
heartfelt thanks to all those people
who've worked so hard to find a very
good compromise for the law for the uh
ai ai act what we're trying to achieve
is to ensure that the European Union can
be a worldwide first by ensuring that we
have clear uniform rules which would
apply to all member states rather than
having competition between
EU member states
The Proposal from the European
Parliament provides an excellent basis
here for a starting point for
negotiations with the council I think
that we'll hope and succeed in adopting
a fully harmonized approach secondly
colleagues
it's always very important with
Innovative Industries such as medical
technology to avoid double regulation
obviously a medical technology AI is
very much present
but uh
we have to ensure that we exclude
duplication with specific sector rules
and I think we've succeeded in doing
that thirdly
a lot of colleagues have expressed their
concerns regarding the starting point
for council with negotiations with the
council they're trying to push those in
a certain direction the Epp has always
said that there it has certain political
concerns which many of our members think
are important
so those those countries which have been
subjected to terrorist attacks have
National concerns which we have to
respect this is why it's important that
we be in a position to vote on those
Provisions
thank you Mr schwart there's a blue card
for you
from Mr slugodinski you have the floor
a colleague a question if I may
do you find it's acceptable that you're
uh actually going against your own
repertoire behind their backs and uh are
there any cases where you know about
facial recognition in the streets in
countries such as Rush where people are
being plucked from the Metro or the
public area and arrested
simply because they were moving through
the public space their face was known
and for political reasons they were then
uh arrested by uh a dictatorial state
isn't there risk that we could also go
in that direction
that was also those arrests were also
based on criminal law measures such as
those which you're calling for here
thank you Mr Lego this is a very
important important point the Epp is
very clear about the fact that total
monitoring and surveillance using AI
should be banned
as this act proposes there are only two
possible exceptions where we will be
calling for a separate vote
this was the case back in the committee
stage so uh we're not trying to act
behind anyone's back the fact is
lots of people's shares that share the
doubts of the Epp in cases such as
missing children and terrorism we think
it's important that we find a solution
so as to ensure that AI can enable us to
implement more or act more quickly than
the legislation makes possible right now
this is a good thing we would of course
talk about this and it's important that
we have a vote on this tomorrow that'll
give us a chance to see what the
majority in the parliament is one thing
is clear however we don't want to become
like China or Russia
thank you the next speaker is
commissioner and Roberta's colleagues
you are taking a history
step
what will happen here this AI act will
boost the AI usage but not forget that
the societies are built on the rules
rules are there for safety Health
democracy rule of law privacy and
environment but now we're here please
globally that do something as people
start to see a AI Solutions in our lives
either special committee and data
strategy have been Paving the way for
balance regulation and two year of work
in the parliament improved already good
commission proposal we don't want to
predict the predictive policing that you
most probably are a criminal nor scoring
citizens by pointing systems and no and
it's good that EP position would also
ban this also Pride the private entities
emotion recognition to be used at your
children's school or at the workplace
Parliament don't last week I spent in
Washington the most common sentence I
heard was we are lagging so much behind
EU so the global interest there and I'm
a strong believer of the Brussels effect
so the definition that aligns
internationally and reaches also the
generative AI helps us to do something
good for the global societies thank you
thank you the next speaker is Miss
katine and you have the floor
president
Madam commissioner
artificial intelligence is developing
incredibly rapidly and of course this
creates enormous possibilities for us
for optimizing logistical chains or in
the area of intelligent transport and
this rapid development of use of AI has
made it very important that we have to
have regulation and ensure that it's
ethical use in an ethical and safe
manner for example we're talking about
facial recognition
and so I'm particularly happy that the
parliament with its point of view is
creating clear rules for a Ai and
especially in the area of smes so they
can
can participate in various tests I think
that's very important for Innovation and
development of products and I think it's
also a good idea that the significance
of regional and local authorities are
taking into account as well because that
way we can strengthen Regional economies
and involve these actors in the process
this is an historical legislative
initiative which makes the EU able to be
play a lead role in regulating AI thank
you Mr as the next speaker we have the
floor
for president
commissioner ladies and gentlemen
governments in France and elsewhere
are dreaming of using machines to
eliminate all nasty people in the world
and if they could if those machines
could just quietly let them know who
goes where with whom what they do
in reality of biometric surveillance has
never enabled us to find a single
terrorist or stop a single attack on the
contrary numerous arrests of innocent
people as many as 99 of them were
innocent
and you talk about exceptions is just uh
deception
you're opening a Pandora's box with
these proposals for exceptions you're
Paving the way to a dystopian future
where we'll have uh a mistrusting
high-tech surveillance State like in
China this will give future and present
and future governments that the
opportunity to use a terrifying tool of
impression we are already subject to
surveillance constant surveillance
surveillance
prevent diversity uh criticism protests
we don't want to live in a society where
people will be afraid to stick their
heads above the parapet
let's ensure that Europe has a future
which is free of mass surveillance so as
to ensure that our future our children
have some hope of living in a future
marked by freedom and uh Independence
thank you now Mr billing has Robert
colleagues please do respect your
speaking time as we're already behind
schedule artificial intelligence is
Transforming Our World at an
unprecedented Pace as it is increasingly
becoming Central to our daily lives our
economy and our democracy it is clear
that this technology holds immense
potential but also carries substantial
risks our first horizontal legislation
on AI introduces among others robust
safeguards against high-risk AI systems
and manipulative practices my group has
been vocal on ensuring a comprehensive
framework in line with other existing
e-laws such as gdpr and DSA as well as
on the regulatory sandboxes supporting
SMS smes and startups in Innovation
testing within every member State I
welcome the fact that these two major
improvements are part of the final
compromise those showing that we are
also committed to fostering innovation
I believe that AI act in its current
form represents our strong commitment to
protect the public interest while
encouraging AI progress thank you
thank you the next speaker is Mr Panzer
you have the floor
thank you president
commissioner colleagues
I've never spent my criticisms indeed
face criticism to the commission but I
recognize that in this instance
because you're on the right course
there's a shared awareness
that we need to pull the economic risk
resources if we're to keep Pace with the
United States so it's important to have
a regulatory framework that will ensure
we have safe use of this technology
there's a huge opportunity here but
there's also great potential for
Destruction
we've heard many distinguished figures
in high-tech Express doubts about the
use of AI
a number of London firms have
urges to be extremely cautious
this technology has instead could
destroy millions of jobs too
and no one affected should be abandoned
lastly just two points first of all
let's be careful
that we don't over regulate as we often
do in this house thereby
dis incentivizing firms to take this up
and that could apply in particular smes
and secondly don't be afraid to use AI
to prevent crimes such as International
terrorism for example because Western
democracies
have guarantees and tools available
which will allow us to use these
Technologies not just to improve our
lives
but also to uphold our safety in the way
thank you the next
um speakers opinion dolly
good afternoon
artificial intelligence is like a river
you can either try to you can try and
block it or direct it but always find a
new route
so
when we try to find and to direct the
course of the river
the European artificial intelligence Act
is an important point of arrival but the
same time we have to be very careful
when it comes to ensuring that the
regulations are properly applied with
technology which is constantly changing
and evolving and which has a real impact
on the competitiveness of European
companies we should never forget that IA
is a product for human beings
and when we use this human system with
these systems we must ensure that human
beings remain in control we should have
constant monitoring and ability to
correct mistakes but this in a loan
won't be enough to labors to face up
this revolution
good policy making which should enable
enable us to predict social and cultural
changes
for example the impact of this on the
world of Labor
then will be the time for us to start
thinking about Universal rules
when it comes to the question of
protection of the data collected and
used we should be able to interview
using cyber security search to ensure
that we don't build a car
a pack of cards which simply collapse
thank you the next speaker is Mr
tataricos
thank you president commissioner
the fact is that today is an occasion to
complement one another for this
initiative that's coming into shape but
let's be realistic there'll be no pause
there'll be no moratorium in the rollout
of artificial intelligence and so we're
facing a phenomenon
went by and we have the greatest
transition of our civilization in
centuries so I think it's also important
for us to adopt a constructive approach
I'm an optimist
that's not just under it's called the
risks but let's also broaden out the
opportunities what we're facing here
is not an irreversible and inevitable
dystopia on the contrary
where before a new age of opportunities
that we can provide leadership for in
the European Union we can lead this
revolution in regulations such as this
we have to facilitate Innovation and
generate confidence we believe the
legislation will meet those goals
furthermore I I I do regret
that legitimate security concerns
I've seen people resorting to look at
China as as a a way of writing this off
no one's talking about China or Russia
we're talking about the European rule of
law addressing our citizens legitimate
concerns
with legitimate exceptions in the use of
available technology thank you
the president please do respect your
speaking time Mr botosh you have the
floor
thank you very much
esteemed commissioner dear colleagues
artificial intelligence can indeed bring
benefits to many sectors of activity and
this is why it's so important to
encourage its development and to make
sure that it is used indeed to bring
welfare to Citizens just like any other
instrumental tool we need to regulate
the fields that pose the greatest risks
when it comes to Human Rights and safety
but we need to keep a balance between
regulation and development
because the EU is not the only place
where artificial intelligence is being
developed and we're lagging behind other
countries uh in this field we cannot
come with strict restrictions if they
are not truly necessary
and then because we want to bring
benefits to all citizens then we need to
make sure that training programs are
adapted to the new realities at all
levels in the European Union in all
member states and that no one is Left
Behind thank you
thank you Miss gazer how's the floor now
Madam president commissioner
colleagues half of all the researchers
in AI said in a survey in 2020 there's a
10 uh
percentage that AI could lead to the
extermination of humanity
and and of course no one would get in an
airplane with those kinds of odds so
that's why we address Aviation Security
and I think we have to do this for AI as
well and it's not just a number of
identifying risk uses but rather
ensuring uh these that these uh
generative models such as chat GPT can
be used safely and what is threatening
us well we could have huge quantities of
disinformation deep deep facts filling
up our media land landscape and so in
with very little effort in time you
could have all this different
disinformation flooding the
media so and this can happen without any
facts and we want to protect democracy
from this and that's what we're taking
an important first step with this new AI
act
thank you the next speaker is Mr fidanza
you have the floor thank you madam
president commissioner some people say
that the European Union has perhaps been
pushing too hard and too fast when it
comes to the evolution of artificial
intelligence over the next three months
and years it might be true
however today rather than destroyment
the details of legislation we have to
agree in one principle whatever changes
take place in technology including those
which have dehumanizing impact
can also serve the interest of human
beings this is what's so important that
we have rules and regulations which
recognize that infrastructure doesn't
always have the same level of danger
privacy intellectual rights consumer
rights Liberty human dignity security
all of those issues we can't allow them
to be undermined this is why it's
important that we carefully understand
the challenges of technology in our
productive society and we have to bear
in mind the need for social balance at
the same time however we have to keep
the window open so as to ensure that we
can continue to cover future changes and
to avoid finding ourselves in a
paradoxical situation where we're simply
obliged to tag along with other Giants
around the world who are able to act
more quickly than us
thank you Mr nutting out the floor
thank you president commissioner
colleagues
this regulation on artificial
intelligence is the first worldwide to
regulate this area providing specific
conditions for the use of these
Technologies the risk-based approach
it does have a number of emissions in it
nonetheless there are a large number of
improvements on the commission's
original proposal brought in by Raff
hotels in their compromise amendments
and of course it's important for band
practices
into being
enforced by proper penalties
the the fear of AI getting out of
control has been flagged by the request
for meritorium by more than a thousand
of experts including Elon Musk in other
developed countries
that there are also calls for more
binding legislation to reduce the risks
to
human safety given that the brake pace
and development of these new
technologies
thank you
the person thank you miss cocoloni you
have the floor
thank you very much Madam president
to reduce emissions and fight cancer
these are just some of the examples of
how development in the AI could
revolutionary revolutionize the world
right now more possibilities and
opportunities and that means more
responsibility and the world is looking
at Europe right now and that's why it's
important that the eu's new unique AI
act works well and it works both in
terms of digitalization but also to
create security for our citizens so I
would encourage my colleagues to vote
Yes in order
to being that the police could use AI to
stop a terrorism to find children we
have to be able to protect our children
we shouldn't be protecting terrorists
because the digitization is already
already here we're not going to allow
the Chinese communist state to determine
the rules for the future it's Europe
which should determine the world the
rules for the world and for
digitalization
thank you vice president uh you have the
floor next I'm commissioner AI is a tool
that will help millions of Europeans
live Better Lives
it will help us cure cancer it will help
us solve problems quicker and yes it can
help us fight crime like terrorism
I do not think AI is a risk but a chance
chance for a better future
it is true that AI is a tool that can be
used for good or misused but it is just
a tool just because I can hit my finger
with a hammer does not mean we should
bend all of them and stop building
houses
just because I can hit my finger with a
hammer doesn't mean that we should stop
developing better and safer tools in the
future
I agree we need guidelines to make sure
we use this tool wisely but Banning
Innovation goes far too far
no technology is without risk we never
would have developed electricity cars or
airplanes if we didn't take a risk I
believe AI like with other technology
will make the future better and I want
it to develop in Europe thank you
thank you very much the next speaker
well Mrs crook
Ed
Madam president this artificial
intelligence Act is the first in the
world the scientists have been already
pointing to certain threats that
artificial intelligence can pose they
warn us that a more powerful digital
engines are being used that cannot be
fully controlled an open letter has been
published recently with hundreds of
signatures of
University Specialists and Company
Specialists which says that artificial
intelligence is a deep threat for
Humanity
this act should guarantee our security
and basic rights for Citizens it bans
usage of artificial intelligence for
example for biometric identification or
manipulation
or a
for the activities of the police which
may be harmful they also oppose them
they have them
[Music]
um they want transparency therefore they
are very important and let's hope that
other acts like this will also appear in
other countries we cannot risk to lose
control over our civilization thank you
thank you very much the next speak with
Mr jeruso
president
colleagues artificial intelligence is an
opportunity
it's a gift of from technological
progress but it can also mean a risk for
our community
artificial intelligence has to be human
centered it has to respect a fundamental
rights as enshrined in the treaties
we need to give space for companies by
increasing legal certainty in all member
states
we need to make it easy for public
authorities and private companies to
respect the obligations let's hope that
we this technology can improve our lives
particularly when it comes to rights but
that's why I'm quite concerned about
facial recognition and other instruments
that could be used for dimiscriminatory
purposes I'd like to thank the raffleter
for all of the work that he's done
and I hope that he does not give in to
dangerous deregulation what this report
does instead is to create a single
digital Market which
can protect rights while allowing the
market to develop our rights and those
are future Generations
thank you very much Mr Alias echeveria
will be the next speaker
thank you very much
the internet has revolutionized our
lives and um
has uh made day-to-day life easier but
it comes with risks when it comes to AI
we're already seeing changes in our
day-to-day lives
we Face significant challenges but
through adopting this new legislation we
can move towards more responsible AI
based on the European principles and
values the European way based on
transparency and protecting uh privacy
as the fundamental pillars we can be
leaders in the world when it comes to
developing AI but we have to continue to
protect and encourage our smes to ensure
that they have the real capacity to be
able to compete and to place Europe on
the digital global map to do that we
need to have confidence
and we are facing a number of challenges
through uh this law transparency
protecting private life and
competitiveness we already know the
opportunities and risks and it's only
about legal certainty that we'll be able
to uh fully develop the full potential
of AI and use it in our daily lives to
our advantage thank you
thank you very much
Madam president Madam vice president
colleagues the European Union is going
to make a major step forward this week
we are the first Institution
the first consonant around the world to
set rules for artificial intelligence
this is an ambitious text it's the
result of two years of work on the part
of the Commission in the parliament
it was sent back to the drawing board to
deal with generative AI like chat GTP
it's going to provide responsibilities
for the providers and designers whilst
quantifying the risks
we need to ensure that we have
trustworthy AI that respects our values
and this brings us to virtually
philosophical interrogations about the
future of our societies as a humanist I
want to ensure that AI is always
controlled by human intelligence we need
to in use this to innovate to change our
jobs and not to destroy them we need to
look at rights for cultural creators
based on the copyright directive and
providing the necessary complementary
legislation
computers will never replace human
sensibility thank you
the next speaker is Mr wrestler
thank you very much
colleagues
as a central technology of Industrial
Revolution artificial intelligence
Works in
unknown previously unknown speed and no
human activity will be and will remain
untouched as all technology it can be
used for good or a bad for better
Medical Technology less monotonous work
but also for dystopians in our scenarios
like a mass control or
uh systems of social control so
therefore we need to set up clear rules
to be able to use all the advantages but
minimize risk we need the safeguards and
caution but
unreasonable
opposition to some uses like a biometric
identification to use missing children
is unreasonable
ladies and gentlemen we need this
historic act we need a legal Security in
Europe but we also need
Innovation and competitiveness in Europe
and this document can give it to us so I
would like to congratulate all of you
who participated in this work it has
been a pleasure for me too and I do hope
that together with the council will
reach a very good framework thank you
thank you very much Mrs Rafael is next
foreign
very good that the European union now
has a new piece of legislation in
preparation in order to deal with this
new horizon that exists before us as far
as AI now ai
is of course something which is
intricately linked with human rights so
we have to look at this particular
Dimension protection social economic
issues uh human rights here a I of
course can't discriminate as well but it
can also work well for Innovation for
efficiency for Speed
to improve the educational system the
labor market as well we have to work
with AI in a positive fashion so it's
good what we need
but there's also that human aspect as
well that has to do with thinking with
intellectual processes I think there is
a good step that has been taken in the
right direction but it's important for
us to make sure that we can guarantee
that legislation will be adhered to and
that human beings will be protected in
this new AI Realm thank you Mr Hitman
thank you very much
Madam president
commissioner artificial intelligence
brings about huge potential but left to
its own devices it can be a source of
serious threats that's why clear legal
framework which identifies the risks of
the uses of AI and imposes obligations
depending on the degree of this risk is
very much needed I'm very happy that the
European Union is the World Pioneer in
putting in place such legislation
because it provides the users of this
technology with trust and also
legal certainty I believe that we should
use the potential of artificial
intelligence for such fundamental issues
like preventing terrorist attacks or
searching for kidnapped or children
although we must guarantee
fundamental human rights and citizen
rights and first of all only upon the
decision of an independent Judiciary
yeah you thank you very much Mr Didier
is next
month
we need to encourage AI but also
regulate it and to do that we need to
take choices
some of these choices are not minor
choices particularly when it comes to
biometric identification we're talking
about things like facial recognition
the right is calling for some of these
cases
some cases to allow this to be used lost
children preventing terrorist Acts
preventing crimes
or where those crimes are punishable
with at least three years of
imprisonment some of the left-wing
groups refuse to use AI
even when it's a question of protecting
children catching criminals
and preventing terrorism
ideology is not as important as security
when there are urgent situations
it seems that some political groups in
this house
are taking a very naive approach they
will have to explain to our citizens
when there is the absolute need to
protect our citizens in Europe
everyone has to take their share of
responsibility
thank you very much I see there's a blue
card request
from Mrs Van sparentak
but Mrs Vance Bannon text already had a
chance to speak so uh
uh we're already behind schedule so
we'll have to move straight along the
next speaker is Mrs del Castillo Vera
thank you president vice president
AI is vital for Innovation and growth
but
something is very key in developing Ai
and it's something we've heard a lot
about today and that is Trust
if people don't have trust in how AI is
used we won't be able to develop its
full potential
we are developing the first European
legislation on AI and this legislation
has to ensure certain ethical
requirements and responsibility and
transparency
uh when we talk about uh high risk
systems that are taking decisions
um for example and it's also important
that we guarantee security
therefore this legislation has to have
efficient tools for instance when we're
talking about preventing terrorist
attacks or finding missing persons
or anything pertaining to children's
lives
here there has to be legal Authority and
a proper use of application Europe
is characterized by its Central uh role
that it gives to human values and this
is what is key in this legislation on
artificial intelligence thank you
[Applause]
the next speaker is Mrs vintig
president
commissioner
colleagues ladies and gentlemen in years
of past the use of a i
that was the turnover that was related
to AI was over 450
445 million dollars these particular
developments of course hide great
chances but also major risks as well uh
we have to take into consideration
threats against democracy as well so we
need legal security for entrepreneurs
for and of course from the SME
Intergroup we wanted to say that AI
indeed very important for smes for micro
industry as well to help them to develop
and move forward thank you yeah thank
you very much that brings us to catch
the eye
well I can tell you I won't be able to
give the floor to everybody who's asked
for it because
I think there are 11 people asking to
take the floor and we are falling behind
schedule
I'll start with Mrs Twitter Dahl
she also made a blue card request which
was not allowed so we'll start with you
thank you very much Madam president the
development of artificial intelligence
means both fantastic possibilities but
also difficult challenges that's why we
need to have very clever legislation at
the European level to allow us to take
advantage of the opportunities
but it's not clever legislation to
prevent AI from being used to improve
our security in Europe the left in the
European Parliament actively is trying
to prevent AI from being used for things
like terrorist attacks which are
underway or kidnappings of children
AI has a potential to save lives and we
want the possibility to use it for those
purposes
the left is also preventing the AI from
being used to for Border controls so we
can better manage migration that's not
clever AI legislation so I hope that
those objections will fall tomorrow
thank you very much with the tala
foreign
thank you very much
over the last hour and a half I've
listened to what the left had to say
with many arguments full of anxiety and
worry and that's actually a Pity but it
was always like that as concerns
digitalization we saw the same thing
now a I will make our will change our
lives at least as much as computers have
had but it isn't as visible it isn't as
palpable if you like as things have been
over the last 20 or 30 years and the
reason is that a I uh will come to its
full-blown uh capability when we come to
optimization as well and while it isn't
that a visible or palpable we find
ourselves in a period where we're still
using uh different other forms of
technology which are of a lower level
card Punch Cards machines and I feel
that indeed we really ought not have
fear of AI but we ought to have a high
level of Regulation so that we can use
it in the most optimal possible fashion
thank you
thank you very much Mrs
president artificial intelligent
intelligence carries a lot of
possibilities with it and it's important
that we create a legislative framework
that Fosters Innovations and research in
Europe and at the same time it is
important to identify possible risks it
is good that Europe is the first
continent in the world
that is creating rules for AI
what it can be used and how and I think
the approach in which uh AI use has been
categorized based on risk is sensible I
think most of the uses are low risk but
when aai starts to make decisions that
have impact on people's education jobs
bank loans
then it is well founded that we have
more control more audit processes
targeted at that
and it is also sensible that certain AI
uses are banned overall in Europe such
as mass control and
identification of people so that is why
I think the epp's position on this is
very sensible we support the commission
uh that AI can be used to enhance
security that we can protect people's
lives and their health
and then I think real-time facial
recognition should be allowed and I hope
that the majority of the parliament can
vote for that
AI brings us a lot of opportunities and
I think Europe should grasp these
opportunities but we must remember that
AI
has certain values attached to it so
that's why we need to think about those
values thank you
thank you very much but you have to keep
your remarks to one minute we've got so
many people asking for the floor so
please respect your speaking time
otherwise no one will be able to speak
Mrs latel March is the next speaker
technology this technology that we're
trying to regulate here could be a very
positive one for public policy
we need to set standards for online
games
we could manage flows of patients at
hospitals we could better manage
European funds they're these are all
projects that are being developed in
Portugal but
we need to be careful in taking
advantage of these opportunities we have
to prevent the Discrimination for
example when someone is refused house
insurance because they live in a certain
neighborhood or if it's used for
selecting candidates for jobs
now this is the first attempt at the
World level to get the right balance
between risk and Innovation giving
better certainty to companies working in
the area and more trust for our citizens
let's hope Madam vice president that
this legislation will be flexible enough
to keep Pace with technological
development
and that is how this legislation will
remain relevant in the long term
Mr Lopez Aguilar is the next speaker
we are
adopting an European law on artificial
intelligence this is one of the main
objectives of this legislature
legislation that will have an impact on
all of our lives
and
what we've tried to do in the Liberty
committee is to try to ensure that this
is compatible with the charter of uh
fundamental Liberties not just ethically
but from a legal standpoint as well to
prevent prohibited uses for example for
instance
predictive policing
or using indiscriminate biometric uh use
of AI or when there hasn't been a crime
this could be discriminatory and is not
in line with non-discrimination that we
have in the charter
we want to ensure that Europe is at the
Vanguard of technological uh development
one that is excellent
now of course the law always comes uh
late given how quickly everything is
developing but we need to send out a
clear message to the world the EU is
determined to keep a check on artificial
intelligence thank you
thank you very much Mr Andrews
thank you chair I'm fundamentally
opposed to the use of AI systems and
remote biometric facial recognition and
in Mass surveillance there have already
been too many cases of mistaken identity
there have already been too many cases
of abuses of the system
to surrender the right of privacy to a
technology that is developing and
evolving as fast as this ai's potential
for positive transformation is vast
especially in medicine and education as
many speakers have pointed out however
as the Godfather of AI Jeffrey Hinton
has said AI also presents an existential
threat to humanity or in the vivid words
of Yuval Nova Nova Hariri it has the
potential to hack the operating system
of our civilization however let's not
forget that AI did not create nuclear
weapons did not create genocide did not
create hate speech left to our own
devices we are more than capable of
moral collapse and that is why it is
important that the legislation focuses
on the intended use of the technology
and not on the technology itself thank
you foreign
ladies and gentlemen we are witnessing a
real Revolution the 21st century is the
age of data artificial intelligence has
become a part of our everyday life but
it's possibilities go beyond what we
have already seen besides benefits there
are also threats which we should
minimize by adopting effective legal
framework that would guarantee the
security and the protection of
fundamental rights of citizens but not
preventing its further development
because then we would be at left behind
in the race for Innovation AI is also an
opportunity for the Polish businesses to
develop because it's much easier to to
build up your position in a newly
developing Branch that's why I believe
that we will become sources of
innovative solutions in an AIA if the EU
is become to a leader in artificial
intelligence it must take advantage of
its strengths and support the
development of safe AI built and
developed in Europe
Mr tally is the next speaker
sorry Mrs Daly AI is being sold to us as
the latest in a series of groundbreaking
technological leaps it'll make our lives
easier it'll make the world a better
place well don't believe the hype like
so much before us AI will be used for
surveillance and control it won't give
us a four-day working week or longer
summer holidays it won't solve the
climate crisis or redistribute wealth it
won't make Public Services better or
policing more effective it'll be just
more the same but faster and probably
much worse that Judicial Systems around
the world are exploring using AI in
judicial decision making should scare
the hell out of us that Ukraine has been
held up as a living la living lab for AI
Warfare is frightening we should be
approaching this subject cautiously like
every new technology instead we're far
too quick to follow industry governments
across Europe are chomping at the bid to
use facial of recognition to hell with
people's rights the Irish government of
MEPS who were in that coming in here
saying they disagree with it but they're
moving legislation before a possible EU
ban the Epp should be ashamed of
themselves for reneging on the heart
hours of negotiation at committee
the next speaker will be the Executive
Vice President Mrs best tiger
thank you very much for this very
far-reaching for this nuanced debate
I hope that it will pave the way for a
good vote tomorrow for a strong
Parliament mandate so that we can get at
it
many many speakers today have touched
upon the fact that Europe is the first
to move
on legislation on binding obligation on
enforcement
but AI develop as we speak and it is
important that we also reach out to
International Partners to see how many
can we bring on board on at least until
we have binding obligations to have the
possibilities for businesses to
voluntarily commit as to how they
develop as to how they enable
third-party controller what they do as
how they have a feedback loop to make
sure that things are done right
nothing
has the right to impeach on the
parliament's position on the trial locks
that we will start and nothing does that
so I think all the many different
approaches to making the world a safe
space where Innovative strong technology
will serve the humans is absolutely
crucial eventually of course we also
need a un a United Nations response to
this and here I hope that this debate
will pave the way because it's a debate
that shows the balances that needs to be
maintained freedom and safety
and it is really the future that we're
talking about how should these balances
be made
between the freedom as many have spoken
off today the freedom of surveillance
the freedom to do what you want without
someone looking over your shoulder while
at the same time the safety to know that
if the worst things happen the police
can do their job
also the balance between Innovation and
of course that risks of our fundamental
rights are being prevented I think these
debates have had it all
I think that you have all hurt and
probably agree that AI is too important
not to regulate and it's too important
to badly regulate
a good regulation that we all agree on
as soon as possible must be a common
objective
and of course that we need sound
enforcements we need these obligations
that this law gives us to be a real
thing on ground for people to be safe
the commission's role is to be an honest
broker between the European Parliament
and the council we will do our best to
facilitate your work in this crucial
file I think I speak also on behalf of
my colleague
myself our services we will of course be
fully available
I am grateful for the Ambitions of the
parliament on this very important file
it has been an impressive debate it is
no exaggeration that the world is
following this work I want to thank you
very much for taking the lead thank you
thank you very much we'll now give the
floor to the rebel term Mr benefay
thank you vice president thank you all
the colleagues for the debate thanks to
my Cora Porter
dragostudorrache and all the shadow
reporters for this great work and also
the contribution to this discussion that
has been uh showing also
um the different angles to which we can
look at the at the topic I think it
emerged very clearly
um that we need to work
um very strongly on
some innovations that came after we have
been starting this work we started doing
it with generative AI with our proposal
on general purpose Ai and this will be
crucial that we maintain this ambition
when we negotiate with the Council on
these topics that are we can say on the
Forefront of the of the work we need to
defend our approach that strengthens uh
fundamental rights that has been clear
um for example with the fundamental
rights impact assessment but also I
think it's important that we put value
to our effort to strengthen Innovation
to support startups with the work on the
sandboxes I think we did a Farah job on
this and I think it's important to
clarify that uh as was said earlier by
the commissioner on that when the worst
happens we can act this is something we
all agree on and we know that with this
text with the text that came out of the
committee with the usage of
non-real-time
biometric identification in cases that
are to pursue crimes that have been
already committed and with the control
of a judge we can uh pursue this balance
I wanted to specify this because I heard
many colleagues speaking on this topic
but I think it's important to clarify
that existing text is already very
Advanced and clear and that's also why I
think we should keep the text that we
voted in the committee we are ready to
work for the upcoming trialogs thank you
for all the work and for the efforts to
put this chamber this Parliament at the
center of the effort to build a
human-centric AI not just for us but for
the whole world thank you very much
thank you very much Mr benefay
will also have concluding remarks
yeah all thank you very much for the
debate today we all use big words
we said change the world transformative
impacts turning point for humankind
oftentimes
we use these words as political
exaggerations but with AI these are
right on point we are facing a turning
point in history many may not see it yet
and we needed a small demonstration
provided by a powerful chatbot over the
past months to alert
leaders and policy makers around the
world but we
here in the EU we are doing something
about it we are taking up our
responsibility as lawmakers to protect
our society from potential harm
and give our economies a clear direction
as to how AI can be used for good of
that
we can all be proud
two last points that I consider
important first
there's also Executive Vice President
vestaga said
is global convergence
as we vote to negotiate these rules we
must look also outward and invest
politically in the effort of a global
framework for addressing the benefits
and risks of AI
Brussels effect is one thing in our
rules will inevitably be a model for
other jurisdictions but we must work
with the sense of shared responsibility
and interest with all our like private
Partners to achieve the geopolitical
objective of having AI alignment and
second
the a revolution must leave no one
behind
we must push our governments to engage
citizens to explain what is coming
to rethink education and risk killing of
our Workforce to face confidently the
transformation around them otherwise all
good intentions May gone to waste so in
the end I make display in front of you
vote tomorrow with this sense of
responsibility and with the satisfaction
that we are on the right side of History
thank you
congratulations
thank you very much that concludes the
debate on this item thank you for
everyone who's Taken part it's very
interesting the vote will take place
tomorrow
let's now move on to the commission
statement on the establishment of an EU
ethics body
will give time for our commissioner to
get settled
when she's ready
I'll give the floor to vice president
Yoruba
then honorable members
I